hi everybody uh my name is adam floyd
i am the commercial operations manager
for
think20 laboratories i'm going to be
giving you a short presentation today
on analyzing terpenes
and hemp so i've got about 11 years of
experience
in the cannabis industry i've done a
tremendous amount of research
on terpenes and very large sorts of
fascination for me i think 20
laboratories we are a
commercial cannabis and hemp testing lab
so we have a dea license for hemp
testing
and we take in samples from all over the
u.s
we have two laboratories one in irvine
california
and one in columbia maryland
so to begin with i'm going to talk a
little bit about
sort of the how hemp is defined so
there's state-by-state regulations
certain states set a limit at
0.3 delta 9 thc
and then there's a federal limit which
is
a total thc concentration of less than
0.3
so this is a combination of the
acidic form so thca
and delta 9.
now in general there's two different
uh major categories of hemp so there's
industrial hemp
which is used for
oil fiber hemp cream
there's tons and tons of paper lots and
lots of industrial uses for this product
um and then the other big category is
cbd
which is mostly what i'll be talking
about today is that as terpenes
uh relate more closely to this
there's also a lot of interest that's
growing in cbn hemp
and cbg but we won't really discuss
those too much today
so first before we get into the uh you
know how we analyze these compounds
i'm going to talk a little bit about
what terpenes are
and how they relate to
the hemp and cannabis experience
so whether you know it or not you've
probably interacted with terpenes
a tremendous amount in your life um
things like pinene are found in cleaners
this is a compound that's present in
pine trees and give it
that very distinct piney scent
mint tomatoes any sort of
uh effervescent plant
most likely contains terpenes and they
are
nearly omnipresent in the plant world
they serve a number of purposes uh
metabolically
so you know they signal
you know they can work as a pest
deterrent and as a chemical signal
so they're aromatic oils um
certain plants have only a few
terpenes there's been well over 200 that
have been identified
in cannabis so this is one of the
reasons that so many of the different
varieties of cannabis and hemp have such
unique scent profiles
metabolically they're secondary
metabolites produced through the
mva mep pathways so these
pathways build these compounds from
repeating units of isoprene so these
uh units uh
determine whether there are monoterpenes
or diaterpenes or sequestoterpines
it's just merely a designation of the
number of units of isoprene
used in their metabolic pathway
and so you hear this term chemovar a lot
it's become fairly popular and i'll talk
about it in a little bit more detail
shortly but basically the idea behind
this is it's sort of
the chemical fingerprint of the strain
of
hamper cannabis so it's why
certain strains uh make you feel
or or smell a certain way so
it is an important part of the hymn
experience
now why why should we care about
terpenes um
they they play a very very critical role
in the the consumer experience
on a very interesting note a lot of the
winners from cannabis cups have
unique and robust terpene profiles
so a very good analogy that i heard
about this was just like you know it's
like the difference between
a four dollar box of wine and a 200
bottle of wine those alcohol
concentrations are almost going to be
identical but one of them provides
a much different experience right
so um just like you wouldn't judge these
wines by
how much alcohol is in them um people
tend to not
judge cannabis based off of the
thc cbd like you'll see that you know a
lot of times there's this focus on high
numbers but really truly the experience
comes from the interaction between these
analytes
and uh the terpenes so
this is this term is has been coined as
the entourage effect
and it's a synergistic uh interaction
between
terpenes and cannabinoids in the human
body so
there's been evidence that shows that
terpenes also interact with the
endocannabinoid system so it's not
too big of a leap of faith to
recognize that they play a part in the
overall experience
so there's thought that you know these
these compounds uh magnifying
therapeutic benefits um a lot of times
they'll heal peer people discuss why you
know what one string makes them feel a
certain way
and another one you know may make them
feel sleepy although that is a
purely qualitative
speculation right so this
it most likely has to do with the
interaction of these compounds
and their brain chemistry so the idea is
that the
sum of each one of these parts is
greater than the
the whole experience
all right now before we get into
analysis we're going to talk a little
bit about
the sample preparation one of the
biggest struggles
with uh analyzing
um hemp and cannabis
is the broad variety of matrices that
show up to our lab so
you know cbd from hemp is put into
everything imaginable from shampoo to
bath bombs
dog treats toothpicks
beef jerky we've seen
everything you can imagine come through
our doors
so this creates some problems um
what there's a term in analytical
chemistry called a matrix effect
so this is sort of everything but the
target analyte that you're looking for
which in this case are terpenes
and their interactions with your ability
to measure them
so sometimes this can amplify you know
give you a false
increase in values or it can diminish
the response from the instrument and
you get artificially lower values
so you know it uh sometimes it takes us
a little bit longer to get
right on point with with some of his
analyses so
sample preparation we use 500 milligrams
of sample
so in analytical chemistry the larger
the sample size that you have
the more accurate your results tend to
be oh this value comes from
the bureau of cannabis control
regulations
so they require for compliance testing
we use 500 milligrams of sample
now for hemp there is not
federally mandated regulations yet
but we've seen a significant increase
in what we call a full panel test
for cbd intent products so these are all
the the heavy metals
and terpenes residual solvents
cannabinoids these are all the required
tests for
cannabis but we've seen people becoming
more and more interested
in this for their hemp products and the
idea is that
they are delivering a safe product to
the consumer which is really
rn gold as well
so for terpenes for for hemp flour
extract
we typically use methanol so we grind up
these 500 milligrams we
dilute it to a total volume of 10
milliliters this creates a 20 to 1
dilution
sometimes we can run into some problems
with
oils so we use a combination of dma
and methanol and that seems to increase
our extraction efficiency
so once the sample is ground and
extracted um so usually we use like
a mill bead or if it's a gummy bear we
will
freeze it in liquid nitrogen and grind
it into a fine dust
and so once this is ground sufficiently
we add our extraction solvent
and then we take a 20 microliter aliquot
out of that
and we use
what's called total evaporative analysis
so the entire
20 microliters is evaporated into the
gas phase
and so once this occurs we're now ready
for our analysis
i'm going to move on to the
instrumentation now
this is our setup so this is a perkin
perkin-elmer instrument
we
all the way to our right is the
headspace sampling system
so if you see on the top of the gc
there's also a liquid injector injector
in this uh
in this image so i'll get into that a
little more in a second
so this second uh box in the middle is
called a gas chromatograph so this is
where
our separation takes place so
chromatography
is the science of separation so you'll
probably
probably heard of a liquid chromatograph
this is a gas command
so both of those technologies are used
to
separate out analytes
and then the detector that we use in our
analysis is called a mass spectrometer
so this allows us to get a mass spectrum
of the the targeting our lights
and it allows us to easily identify
the compounds that we're looking for so
i'll get into that
in a little more detail in a minute
so we're going to start with the sample
injection system
so you can see all the way on the right
this is a 40
unit carousel we have 110 unit
carousel in our lab which basically
allows us to run continuously
so the sample is put into a 22
milliliter vial and sealed
and then it's rotated into the auto
sampler oven
where it's baked for uh 10 minutes at
160 degrees celsius
so this allows us to inject only
the compounds that we want to so
majority of terpenes so at least the
ones that we look at boil below 160
degrees
so everything that in the sample that
boils above that will remain in the vial
so once all of these uh analytes are
volatized
we inject a specific volume
into the inlet that is uh moves into the
column
and so the alternative to headspace is
liquid injection
which is a much more messy
methodology so basically you can see on
the right of this picture
is a sample vial um
there's a lot of chlorophyll and other
compounds so there's well over a
thousand compounds
found in the cannabis plant
so not all of those we want to look at
um you can see in that injection liner
there
that's that's after only seven
injections
you can see all that uh sort of
nastiness caught in the lighter
so these need to be changed quite often
at least weekly i've heard from certain
labs they change them every 25 to 30
samples
so this kind of creates a production
nightmare
oh headspace is a much cleaner
technology
i've heard of labs not cleaning their
source
or doing any sort of maintenance in this
regard for multiple years
with that with the total evaporative
analysis
headspace technique now you can
theoretically
measure samples directly with headspace
which is pretty cool
so we found that this works really well
for the actual flower so you can take
the
flour and put it in a vial and heat it
and everything that we
want to measure will volatize directly
off that flour
now this doesn't work as well for oils
and some of these other
complex matrices that we see
so once this once we have our
sample volatized it's now injected into
the gas chromatograph so gas
chromatography it's an
analytical technique that is used to
separate out
volatile compounds so inside these
columns which are typically
30 15 or 45 meters in length
they're wound very tightly
inside here and they have what's called
a stationary phase which is a thin
film on the inside of these capillary
columns
which the our target analytes will
interact with
so in chemistry we always say light
dissolves light so if you think about
oil and water
this kind of illustrates the inner
potential interactions with these
these columns so once we've injected
we have a temperature
a program temperature wrap which slowly
eludes the compounds off of the column
one by one into our detector
so in this next slide on the right is
a typical chromatograph
so here in this one we're looking at 42
different terpenes
so there's well over 200 terpenes that
have been identified in hamp
we have two different methodologies that
we run in our lab so
or compliance testing and the majority
of our
analytics analytical testing we do we
look at
only 21 of these terpenes
from our experimentation we found
there's roughly 17 that
are present in
high concentrations in most hemp samples
so
in order for us to run the these 200
terpenes
it would take well over an hour
and on a 500 000
plus instrument so it doesn't it's not
really feasible to measure all those
compounds
in a commercial type setting
so the run time for 21 terpenes is about
10 minutes
um we're a little bit hindered by
the headspace so it's about a total
from sample injection to complete data
collection it's about 15 minutes
so we can run about 70 plus samples in a
day
and then 42 terpenes is a little longer
about 14 minutes
so once these samples they come off one
by one
we're able to collect spectral data
using our mass spectrometer so mass
spectrometry
is a technique that allows us to measure
uh the charge ratios or
mass to charge of individual ions so
once these are separated and they move
into the mass spectrometer
they come in contact with what's called
a source
so in this case it's electron impact
which creates these ions so it basically
splits them into pieces and then
we use the instrument that we use for
this
is a single quadrupole so it's four
rods that utilize a oscillating
electric field that only allows certain
masses through
so it helps us eliminate
significant noise from entering the
detector
which allows us to have a quick run time
and then also be able to um
definitively determine what analytes
we're looking at
so the detector in this case is an
electron multiplier tube
so it basically uh amplifies the signal
and then we're allowed we're able to
collect a mass spectrum
so on the right here you can see on the
top and bottom these are two typical
mass spectrums from different terpenes
so these vast spectrums are basically
like a chemical fingerprint
so we can tell we can run this against
a database library and determine
exactly which
terpenes are in our sample so even if
we're
not able to quantitatively provide a
value
we can also you know if we get other
hits that we're not looking for
we can still determine what those
turbines are
and so our calibration so terpenes
typically are linear across a broad
range
i think in this we typically run from
about
two parts per million up to five hundred
terpenes you know they rarely exceed
one to two percent by total weight fruit
and flour
um although with extracts things like
live resins this sometimes can be an
issue
so usually we use this 20 to 1 dilution
and
it's sufficient for about i would say 90
plus percent of our samples
the highest chirping concentration i've
seen in flower was four percent
so it does happen occasionally in that
case we just uh
dilute and run it again
um okay if if you guys have any
questions or comments or thoughts or
want to learn more about any of this i'm
i love talking about terpenes and
analytical chemistry so
please feel free to reach out to me my
email is adam.floyd
um thank you very much for attending my
seminar